when we say change lives change
organizations and change the world we
really mean it stanford gsb equips
students to do that
you first have to start by changing
yourself
students are naturally encouraged to
innovate broadens your perspectives on
how to influence how to lead i learned
to be a critical analytical thinker i
understand the global context of
management at the gsb i can meet
virtually the whole world while standing
at this place i have access to a lot of
leaders of international organizations
people who start their own companies
film directors bankers and private
equity consultants renowned leaders from
around the world nobel prize winners
it's really a transformational
experience change lives change
organizations change the world i just
came back from the stanford china
exchange program austria swizzle and
kenyan rwanda when the faculty come on
these trips we can bring that experience
directly into the classroom
it's been inspiring complicated
exciting we met the head of marketing of
red bull a meeting with bayern capital
we're meeting with shanda the best
streaming company in china president
kagame the person of rwanda daniel ramoy
the former president of kenya the
minister of industry and commerce and
lessons learned from gsb alums were
amazing senior nights are very
warm-hearted to give us great career
advice
we have a group of alumni who have had
incredible impact in the world
individuals who who have lived our
mantra change lives change organizations
and change the world hopefully change
all three
so i'm really interested in
entrepreneurship and innovation energy
clean tech space we're working in
tourism improve private equity combining
business medicine stanford gsb believes
in the individual's ability to affect
change make a difference in the lives of
you know hundreds millions of people
pursue your dream dream on a world scale
change lives change organizations and
change the world
you